qu'est-ce que Olivier de Kersauson a
fait de pire dans la vie
sans bonsoir bonsoir pour être avec nous
ce soir vous avez quitté la Polynésie
merci
c'est vrai que c'est sympa la Polynésie
génial le problème c'est qu'il faut
supporter Antoine qui crie à toi les
opticiens
alors Olivier vous avez 69 ans vous êtes
l'un des anciens pensionnaires des
Grosses Têtes de Philippe Bouvard fait
aujourd'hui partie de la bande à Ruquier
mais j'ai découvert que vous aviez une
passion méconnue vous feriez du bateau
c'est vrai ce connerie quoi c'est vrai
vous avez jamais été tenté de quitter
votre boulot d'humoriste de tous les
laisser tomber pour faire je sais pas
moi le tour du monde à la voile
j'ai été tenté j'ai succombé avec délice
alors avant de parler de votre nouveau
livre on va parler de votre nouvelle
femme elle est très jolie je vois pas
pourquoi j'aurais pris une moche
Olivier
69 ans
j'aime bien alors vous avez eu un coup
de cœur à votre âge en général on dit
plutôt à ricardiaque mais
non la nature m'a dotée d'une
constitution qui permet que le cœur
marche encore
ça y est j'avais une alliance là je peux
pas avoir de trucs sur les mains
accrocher c'est dangereux moi aussi je
vais me marier mais c'est une bonne
nouvelle alors fini les courses autour
du monde parce que je l'ai vu la Sandra
moi je laisserai pas toute seule en
Polynésie
alors comme disait Gainsbourg en parlant
de bambou c'est pas la première mais ce
sera sûrement la dernière non
alors on passe le livre maintenant trois
ans après Ocean Song qui a été un
best-seller vous publiez ou cherche midi
le monde comme il me parle trois ans
c'est le temps qu'il vous faut pour
claquer vos droits d'auteur en gros
ouais c'est à peu près ça
je voulais faire un livre danse de
réflexion sur l'amour la mort la
coiffure
alors vous revenez sur votre vie vos
courses vos records mais surtout sur
votre parcours intérieur votre
cartographie intime et on apprend des
choses par exemple votre désir de
solitude qui remonte à très loin et un
jour vous visitez dachaux et là vous
vous dites si le groupe est capable de
ça alors il faut se méfier du groupe ah
ouais moi la sensation physique
je trouve que le notre société le
fabrique des groupes et si le groupe
n'est pas n'est pas piloté avec des
désirs et des pensées qui dépassent le
mot économique le groupe va dans le mur
c'est que le groupe ne peut faire que
des choses négatives ou pas très
intéressantes et que moi j'estimais que
le mon seul capital c'était mon temps de
vie et il m'entend de vie devait se
passer à autre chose c'est pour ça que
j'ai jamais adhéré à aucun parti aucune
secte aucune chose de grosses têtes
c'est une sorte de secte c'est pas parti
c'était c'était un hold-up ça n'a rien à
voir
c'était j'allais très madame RTL c'était
bien
alors vous aimeriez bien être seul à
Vaux-le-Vicomte c'est un endroit qui
vous plaît particulièrement je trouve ça
très joli Versailles c'est trop grand
vous le vicomte c'est la bonne taille
voilà il faut un peu de personnel avec
des patins à roulettes mais ça se trouve
voilà ou alors soit vous le vicomte soit
vous acceptez effectivement de vivre
avec Sandra un Moorea une fille qui a 30
ans de moins que vous ça vaut toutes les
émotions du Cap Horn non
en train de faire Masha les conseils du
cœur arrête
j'ai trouvé une femme qui veut bien de
moi je suis vraiment content et ça se
passe moi aussi
alors on va continuer ce voyage intime
avec une interview Kersauson parkerso
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que vous ne supportez pas je
suis Olivier de Kersauson
son absence
qu'est-ce que Olivier de Kersauson a
fait pierre dans la vie
venir ici
[Rires]
quelle erreur Olivier de Kersauson a
trop souvent commises
erreur de calcul
qu'est-ce qu'il a son Olivier de
Kersauson
sa présence dans la durée il faut
prendre en petite dose pas avec qui
Olivier de Kersauson a-t-il été injuste
à peu près tout le monde jusqu'à l'âge
de 30 ans
beaucoup moins de gens à partir de 40
à 65 et avec moi depuis 65
qu'est-ce que Olivier de Kersauson
devrait arrêter
de fumer en cachette ah c'est bien
qu'est-ce qui n'est pas très joli joli
chez Olivier de Kersauson le dos
quel est le défaut majeur de Olivier de
Kersauson
l'indifférence quand avez-vous eu envie
de frapper Olivier de kersausan pour la
dernière fois jamais j'ai trop peur de
la réponse
quelle taille
qu'est-ce que Olivier de Kersauson
devrait apprendre
à être gentil
qu'est-ce qui est vrai dans ce qu'on
reproche Olivier de Kersauson à mon avis
rien
à dernière question qu'est-ce que
Olivier de Kersauson essaie de cacher ce
que cache tout être humain qui réfléchit
c'est-à-dire cette cette notion profonde
qui nous habite de notre propre
impuissance waouh et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de innarditude abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu